hey this is something very very
interesting
uh rioting as a family affair
a mother and son rioted together on
january 6th isn't that loving is is that
an act of love would we call it that
they've now both been arrested okay new
york mother and son arrested in theft of
pelosi's staff laptop during the capitol
riot nbc news reporting that the fbi
have arrested marianne mooneyrondon 55
and her son
rafael rondon 23 of watertown new york
in connection with a stolen laptop
according to court documents this is
actually out of alaska
which is where they ended up finding the
computer apparently a new york mother
and son have been charged with theft in
aiding the disappearance of a laptop
belonging to the staff of nancy pelosi
during the trump riots after the fbi
initially raided a home
miles away from dc
in alaska looking for the computer the
fbi have arrested as i mentioned
marianne mooney rondon and her son
rafael rondan in connection with that
laptop used only for presentations
according to court documents both also
face other charges related to the riot
at the capitol raphael rondon also faces
possession of classic an unregistered
sought off shotgun both were in federal
court friday in syracuse new york
released pending further proceedings now
there's even a question you know the
trumpets have been saying these folks
are being treated so unfairly held and
sought off shotgun
rioting at dc and they're just released
pending further proceedings if anything
it seems these folks may be treated very
lightly by the criminal justice system
so far
break into the capital
steal pelosi's laptop
sawed off shotgun charge and just walk
free pending further proceedings now
there's there's significant reform to be
done here uh but the point is the
argument that they're all being treated
disproportionately unfairly for
political reasons clearly it doesn't
apply to everybody
um capital riot was well documented by
those who took part
a tip to the fbi led them to the mother
and son according to a statement of
facts documented by an fbi special agent
mooney rondon that's the mom allegedly
admitted to being in both the capital
uh the day of the riots as well as nancy
pelosi's conference room she allegedly
provided gloves or a scarf to a man to
steal the laptop without leaving
fingerprints
he asked he said give me i don't know if
it was gloves or a scarf i was wearing
and like i said he scared me the
document quotes her as saying
um there's also another interesting
thing here
that i think is relevant oh the level of
premeditation okay they want to push the
idea that everything was spur of the
moment look at this raphael rondon
that's the son told police officers that
he and mother
took the metro on january 6th quote
because i'm not taking my car into the
city which the capitol building i'm
about to break into
really undercuts the idea that this was
some kind of spur of the moment thing
they seem to be saying we at least
suspected that things were going to get
sort of crazy and so we deliberately
didn't bring the car we took public
transit instead
at least some degree there of for
knowledge or premeditation
um so we will we will follow this case
as we're following other cases
but mother and son mother and son can
you imagine and the stories about these
individuals i mean listen i'll i'll be
transparent
you read about many of these stories
they're just sad it's it's sad people
but that doesn't mean that they
shouldn't be held accountable and in
fact we're going to talk about that in
the next segment which is there has not
been nearly enough accountability for
the trump rioters we'll get to that
after this short break